i
[Música]
a
el presidente estadounidense donald
trump continúa su recuperación por la
cob y 19 en la casa blanca a la que
llegó el pasado lunes pero lo hace
trabajando muchos le han criticado
porque consideran que estaría poniendo
en riesgo a todo su equipo por no hacer
esa cuarentena que se pide a las
personas que han dado positivo en kobe
19 pero donald tram asegura que se
encuentra cada vez mejor que contagiarse
del coronavirus ha sido una bendición de
dios y que ya está preparado para volver
a retomar los actos de campaña este
mismo sábado dice que él está limpio y
que ya es inmune al virus algo que ni
siquiera la ciencia ha podido demostrar
porque no se sabe cuánto tiempo duran
estos anticuerpos en las personas que
han contraído la enfermedad
donald tram ha sido tratado con una
combinación de medicamentos
experimentales de acceso limitado y él
mismo ha dicho que quiere que todos los
estadounidenses puedan tener acceso a
estas medicinas incluso ha insistido en
que pretende ofrecer las de manera
gratuita
[Música]
el presidente jair bolsonaro anunció que
había contraído el coronavirus en julio
de este año lo hizo de forma polémica
quitándose la mascarilla en cuanto
hablaba con los periodistas y además
desde el primer momento fiel a su estilo
quitó hierro al asunto permaneció muy
activo en las redes sociales donde llegó
a hacer publicidad para el polémico
medicamento hidroxi cloroquina al igual
que melania trump su esposa michelle
también anunció que había contraído la
enfermedad de forma leve pocos días
después de su marido lo más curioso es
que la sociedad civil desconfío de
bolsonaro por un episodio que aconteció
en marzo al principio de la pandemia
hubo un viaje oficial a miami y más de
20 personas de la delegación que viajó
con el presidente dio positivo al test
bolsón aaron dijo que no que no lo había
contraído pero no quiso mostrar los
resultados de los exámenes y lo hizo
solo cuando fue obligado por un tribunal
después de la petición de un periódico
nacional allí se descubrió que había
sido usado un seudónimo y esto generó
mucha desconfianza una parte de brasil
no le creyó cuando dijo que no tenía el
corona
y otra parte de brasil tampoco le creyó
cuando dijo que lo tenía
[Música]
en bolivia la presidenta ya nine años
también ha sido diagnosticada con kobe
19 en momentos en que el país atravesaba
por el punto más alto de la curva de
contagios de coronavirus en aquella
ocasión ella se ha recluido en la
residencia presidencial desde donde ha
continuado gobernando por medios
digitales sus médicos han señalado que
ella ha sido una paciente asintomática
lo curioso del caso es que también ha
sido diagnosticados con kobe 19 la mitad
de los miembros de su gabinete de hecho
dos de los ministros han ido hasta
terapia intensiva hasta que finalmente
todos se han recuperado del cob y 19 la
mandataria recordemos era candidata
presidencial en el país luego ha
renunciado a esa postulación y durante
sus actos de campaña y también durante
sus actos de gestión ella ha lucido sin
barbijo y sin tomar medidas de
bioseguridad actualmente la presidenta
junto a su gabinete están abocados a
preparar la transición democrática rumbo
a las elecciones del 18 de octubre para
entregar el manu
al nuevo gobernante
[Música]